hey guys this is Cameron and welcome
back to motion science in this video I'm
gonna talk to you very quickly about an
expression that I love to use all the
time on a good majority of my projects
that expression is the wiggle expression
and I use it in a slightly different way
I use it on the opacity channel let me
show you what I mean so in this image
what I want to accomplish is I want to
create a flicker effect on these two
light bulbs and I'm gonna do that by
using the wiggle expression so let me
show you how first thing I'm going to do
is I'm going to duplicate this layer and
I'm gonna go to effect blur and I'm
gonna go with the compound blur what I'm
doing here first I'm creating a glow
effect a very simple glow effect so this
image I'm working with is very high-rez
so I'm going to increase the amount of
blur quite high so although that
probably works from 220 I'm also going
to create a mask
and then I'm going to make this mask a
little longer
vertically I'm doing that because if I
turn this layer off I like how this
filament is very vertical instead of
proportionally vertical and horizontal
so I'm creating the mask to emulate the
more vertical oblong shape so we turn
this layer back on I'm gonna go to set
the mode to screen and there you go
there's our very simple glow I'm also
going to feather the edges here quite
high maybe around there I'm gonna go
ahead and drag out sides of the mask
somewhere in there and then I'm gonna
drop the opacity of this layer down to
about 68% so now we have a nice soft
glow on this front light bulb and I
think what I'm gonna do now is I'm going
to duplicate that layer and I'm going to
take the mask I'm going to scale it down
so it covers this bulb back here maybe
make it a little bit wider actually a
little bit taller
like so and because this bulbs more in
the background I'm going to drop its
opacity to about half and I'll just to
keep things tidy I'll drop it below so
this is the foreground bulb
and this is the background Bowl
and this is the original image so how do
I make these flicker well it's real
simple like I said I use the wiggle
expression so I alt or option click on
the Mac on the opacity I type in wiggle
parenthesis 10 comma 20 in parentheses
and then I hit enter on the keyboard and
for those of you who don't understand
expressions
I want the frequency to be 10 times per
second at a rate amplitude of 20 which
20 has to do with the opacity here so
since I was set originally to what was
it 69 percent capacity I'm saying you
can go up by 2 89 % or as low as 49% so
it's a factor of 20 and I'm gonna do the
same thing on the background layer
wiggle parenthesis and because this is a
little bit further in the background I'm
gonna make the frequency a little less
so let's make it 7 times per second and
20 but remember the opacity on this
layer was set to about half of what the
top layer was 32 percent so it's gonna
go up to 52 percent or all the way down
to 12 percent so instead of hitting
enter I'm just gonna click outside the
expression this time to enable it and
now when I do a preview
you can see the flickering effect taking
place and that's what I've got for you
today it's a really simple flicker glow
effect with the wiggle expression I use
this all the time on projects to make
lamps or candles or lights or or
whatever any type of light source have a
slight flicker to it it just adds a
little subtle subtlety to the to the
light effect it can be a quicker flicker
it can be a slower flicker whatever it
is for your taste but it's it works
really well and like I said I use it all
the time so that's what I got for you
this week I hope you learned something
new please like comment below until next
time I'm Cameron and this is motion
science